il centro smettere dei space di tagli di
capelli assurdi pd ma listri mostrine
dorate abbiamo già fatto altri video del
genere siano divertiti un talk la però
mi sembra che abbiamo fatto solo io da
sola poi questa volta anche vitale vedrà
dei tagli di capelli finiti malissimo
lasciaci un bel è che se volete vederne
altri mettetevi comodi poco nominato non
perdetevi coprire da soli e con le
forbici a casa mi raccomando però devo
linate verso mostrato i capelli il
rotore monoliticamente la pentola con
l'acqua è finito così alta che l'ha
comprato da fare simon ha detto che
questo tondo fa i boccoli insomma no no
no no no non lo fai se rimane incastrato
e difficilissimo da togliere quello non
lo devi mai arrotolare conquista un
seggio così una loro deliziare ha visto
facevo male mi fanno male i capelli a
vederla poveri strappando dove può
andare in giro con la spazzola pesa
piccolina
un video quali battagliando con una
forbicina piccola questo è già più
grande non è bambina
no non citati anche a casa con la
forbice bellissimi questa piastra 60.000
francia poi con quella forbicina così ma
il risultato è garantito orrendo torto
bellissime bene non è terribile però
sono un po storti purtroppo ora aspetto
di andata
magari poi escono benissimo chissà forse
uno bagnato quindi adesso vedremo il
risultato non mi dire sta continuando a
tagliarli o per l'altro lato 9 dic e
sono più porta un altro più lungo
la maggior impegno a tutti assieme avere
un bel mazzetto di cappelli sarà
cortissimo non fare un pezzo così al
contrario
dai procura rivedere risultato
giustamente brutta che di tempo
questo è il risultato
dai non sono terribili diciamo forse un
portento sono terribili
guarda la battaglia rimane perché gli ha
fatto gli accordi dall'altro lato il
signore li deve accorciare ancora di più
non è un circolo vizioso che non ce
n'era mai ma come scudi quale per
esempio di quanti cosi allora ha detto
sei stanco di non di non sembrare è un
aspetto da figo come detto non è che io
sembro figo io sono figlio mi ha detto
ti aiuterò a risolvere il suo problema e
ti aiuterò a fare una sfumatura nei
capelli
ti servirà uno di questi pettini non sa
quale si è un elastico dal dentista sono
quelli già presenti ma perché non mi
vedrete il cappello è solo elettrico s
oddio no non la pressione che sarò
l'allucinante tagliarla centro viaggiare
fatti degli altri pietro non fate queste
cose e se insomma coda se faccio una
treccina vivo una legge beato chi dice
che va a rialzare le codette oddio
beh sicuramente to fail ha quindi dice
di emettere questo dei lacci di scarpe
dove vuoi che inizi la sfumatura
ottimale proprio rosea oggi tutto il
match
il taglio a scodella sfumature a vediamo
nessuna stella permette la scodella poi
quasi tutto intorno ad esso in modo
preoccupare se non per usarli tutti ma
forse riuscirà a stupirci e farà una
bella sfumatura vediamoci ma cosa senza
specchio tra l'altro come a capire dove
sta andando e 70 nutriti il comparto
rientrano però aver alzato troppo il suo
my man dal carcere dopo quella con le
mani e dalle mani e riuscì dovreste
riuscire a capirlo parlerò in tenda
dritto per niente poverino
penso di averlo fatto molto bene
niente il video fisico di seguito invece
per partire dal centro massaggi fuoco
dice che lui è un barbiere quindi
dovrebbe farli bene ok allora in pratica
ha fatto una sorta di contorno linea sì
però mi sembra che sta andando troppo
indietro troppo e quindi rimane poi
quattro senza capelli particolari da
fermati fatta
a un a fronte dell'enorme des deux
preferite non era pronta e che grazie
alla pronta enorme unica soluzione lazar
lì tutti i sei reso conto che è andato
un po troppo oltre
anche pettinando di non smart four se il
problema è che anche in alto possibile
non vedeva ho visto a castronovo vista
per evitare mi sa che non la filt e
guarda sto facendo una sorta di francia
ha tagliato uscita po troppo alta perché
non sta proprio male questo è un
coloratissimo gru e ruota no perché
o no che peccato
[Musica]
oddio quanti sono tra l'altro
lunghissimi no
lunghissime a tutti forse sbagliando la
messa troppo torto se succede alle volte
successo deriva da scappa faccio
un'altra frangia questo è un metodo per
fare la francia un po complicato però
comunque soglio sintesi nelle tecniche
per farla dritta serie puntiamo anche
stavolta al contrario delle brink è una
tecnica per tagliare i capelli rossi
facile sbagliare magari il telefono bene
sembrano però sembra ok
oddio
[Musica]
se ti trovi parte forse la mamma
arrabbiata però non la ferma a tutti la
mamma lascia perdere si è rimasta lì a
guardare questo voglio proprio vedere
dice la mamma anche bei capelli che
s'aprono sorti dei capelli bellissimi
tra l'altro essere del rovinati povera
perfetta sono tipo scalati ma troppo
lì però sembra tranquilla una strada
statura è generata no sta piangendo ma
non capito
[Applauso]
in seguito è fatto uno scherzo un po
brutto forse il viaggio il suo che non
doveva tagli anni così corti di novoli
due piccoli non toccate le forbici e non
toccate errato dire inter come o poter
usare dagli altri adesso sia la mamma
non vuole tagliarglieli quindi sono
questi si no tra 3 ott io sto usando al
contrario a si no ops positivo ora
loretta perché grande
oggi anche nei piccoli che come
immigrato sarebbe una mossa da piccolo
ha detto che ha tagliato i capelli di
altre persone ma mai i suoi o di farsi
nazionale resta tifo
addio ad essi milos e la cresta 0 0 1
ecco perché non vi dovete mai fare da
soli capelli
adesso che è stato non è stato bravo a
scuola se tu vuoi essere cattivo a
scuola questo è quello che ricevi oddio
terribile come manzione penso molto
esagerato a questo povero bambino
riguarda traumatizzò tra l'altro
poverino i capelli bellissimi
[Applauso]
però questo è un parrucchiere quindi
dovrebbero essere vero uscire bene
[Applauso]
wow che fino a non vederli tagliare così
vedi questa è la richiesta ogni serio
ma questi sono usciti bene non sono sei
[Applauso]
no perché i capelli così lunghi deve
essere anche complicato no
[Musica]
wow che coraggio di avere un sacco di 40
portarli tutti e ora il target in gergo
vediamoli che il colore gli altri
colorati completamente rossi se fossi
sua incredibile però non fa male
ottimo differenza però è troppo bello
vedere con dettagli da percorsi non lo
so perché no mi dispiace che invece
guarda quanto le particelle a lunghi
lino mi sembra molto lunghi all amico ma
chi me l'ha fatto fare
secondo me aveva la faccia arrabbiata
mannaggia tra spettacoli che sono venuta
qui gli ho detto panda sono alcuni
ingegneri soldi 2 cm ok 20 critica che
questi erano bellissimi dall'estrema
monterosso come taglio lo bello vederle
straniere così in una linea perfetta con
qualifiche tutti i di sempre corti un po
wavy con un po di sfumature bionde che
non era la musica pe
da rocha ospitò poi preferito i capelli
corti lunghi o mesi lo zio questo la
piazza dopo i corsi si dice 20 secondi
ne ho visto uno simile gli si sono
staccati completo in provincia ma sono
finte cioè che belle normale micro
ibrida visti soprattutto se sono
danneggiati come verifica
ma stiamo scherzando che paura
il fuoco deve sito effettivamente anche
lei l'ha detta la realtà è che poverina
c'è un problema e chissà quanto tempo
travi incastrata e difficilissima da
togliere adesso e dice non posso
tagliarlo perché troppo grande il ciuffo
dice non so nemmeno come è potuto
succedere ma che male io sono ma lo farà
l'editing come l'hanno fatta
e così dopo troppo bene tutti saprebbero
tv ha fatto ridere di più la sua tesi
timestamp nei commenti lo stato un bel
light se volete vederne altri ora vi
lasciamo con quattro cartelline su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite